hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja da ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut
heute haben wir beziehungsweise was
heißt heute das video zieht sich ein
bisschen länger habe ich hab nämlich was
ganz ganz mildes vor und zwar pflege ich
jetzt morgen spontan zu meinen eltern in
den urlaub nach spanien genauer gesagt
jetzt erst mal nach ibiza und dann rüber
auf so eine kleine insel recht über
schön da ich war auch schon 20 mal nur
wir machen so ein kleines experiment
noch nicht mal in deutschland ist es
auch ganz schön anregt werden weswegen
ich auf alle verteilt nämlich vor bin
hier wegzukommen für eine woche ihr
könnt euch sicherlich an meine koffer
videos erinnern ich habe drei koffer
ersteigert die kennt ja schon habt schon
ausgepackt daraufhin hat mir einen
zuschauer geschrieben meint er hat auch
ich konnte das super gerne jemanden der
hat auch bei der koffer option mal was
ersteigert das waren herren koffer und
er meinte er könnte mit dem verfügung
stellen und dann dachte ich mir das ist
eigentlich ganz lustig weil wenn ich das
nächste mal verreisen kann ich mal eine
woche versuchen aus dem koffer zu leben
also wirklich ich schwöre ich werde eine
woche nur aus diesem koffer legen sollte
das geht ich bin mittlerweile schon
angekommen urlaub jetzt als spoiler
dieses ding war auch im café und ok das
andere zeichen und nicht das zeige ich
euch gleich also ich später rein gebt
euch mal und hoffe also noch mal kurz
zur erklärung wie das zustande kam ich
plötzlich hier einige hat jemand
geschrieben erst einmal coole videos die
30 haben wir sehr gerne die koffer
unboxing videos angeschaut ich habe vor
einiger zeit auch mal eine koffer option
besucht und zwei koffer ersteigern mit
den meisten sachen konnte ich leider
überhaupt nichts anfangen ein handgepäck
koffer war dabei da habe ich so gut wie
nichts entnommen sind auch zum größten
teil nur klamotten und spielzeuge drin
vielleicht kannst du damit was anfangen
möchte ich sehr gern ich kann ihn hier
gerne drüber schicken du brauchst nur
noch kein geld dafür geben da steht hier
sowieso seit monaten nur in der ecke rum
auf jeden fall länger korrekt danke
nochmal schön grüßen nicht nico
daraufhin habe ich geschrieben dass ich
tatsächlich was damit anfangen kann mir
kam halt diese video.de aber ich brauche
den koffer dann auch schnell weil der
urlaub geplant genau und jetzt sitze ich
hier durch und an dieser stelle wird
sich um mega freuen wenn ihr einfach mal
ein abo oder last weißt du nicht gemacht
habe wir auf jeden fall sehr geil und
vielleicht erreicht dann doch irgendwann
mal ein paar abonnenten mehr
sie haben wie marie ich muss ehrlich
sein das ist mein rucksack den habe ich
auch noch dabei da ist ganz viel kamera
equipment drin mein laptop und auch noch
ein paar unterhosen meine zahnbürste hab
ich nicht eingepackt da würde ich mir
vor ort kaufen und leute jetzt kommt man
mit
hier haben wir den koffer ich muss sagen
der ist erstaunlich leicht also maximal
fünf sechs kilo aber was soll's ich bin
verrückt ja ich bin ich hab dich ziehst
durch leute weil das ding ist es ist
doch scheiße war mir ist das egal ob ich
meine ruhe ich sonst kaum ich mir
irgendwo sind
ich freue mich auf jeden fall extrem auf
die woche wir fahren jetzt erst zu marie
und morgen geht mein flieger vom
düsseldorfer flughafen die wohnung ist
soweit sauber bis auf den boden das ist
aber gar kein problem wir checken jetzt
ab und dann macht das hier mein neuer wo
ist hier haben wir ihnen den ex djn 8
pro danach crowe ist nämlich der
verbesserte nachfolger von osmond 950
die saugkraft pro ist um 73 prozent
stärker er besitzt eine trudi tags 3d
technologie und das zu mapping system
das waren jetzt ein paar fachbegriffe
die aber wichtig sind wenn ihr euch für
sorg roboter interessiert mit ex habe
ich in der vergangenheit auch schon
öfter zusammengearbeitet und die dinger
sind wirklich geil ich habe hier sowieso
ein bei mir in der wohnung ich habe
einen in meinem büro und ihr könnt ihr
jetzt mal den song botter im einsatz
sehen falls sich an wie ein
feuerwehrauto im einsatz
so wie ich bin auch aufgehoben
[Musik]
wir können euch ganz entspannt die ex
app auf euer handy ziehen und dann in
einer pro damit connecten von eurer
wohnung oder von eurem haus werden dann
automatisch per laser die umrisse
erstellt und ihr habt verschiedene räume
die auch manuell auswählen können nach
der reinigung wird der sound roboter
wieder automatisch zur station lädt sich
auf und theoretisch kann der elektro
sogar vision so hier habe ich mein
persönliches shuttle zum flughafen kann
jetzt mal los leute meinen flieger geht
um halb zwölf wir haben jetzt halb zehn
und hinten im kofferraum ist der koffer
drin und hier habe ich halt noch meinen
rucksack aber gut
es habe ich als athlet wir sehen uns am
flughafen oder vielleicht auch schon in
spanien heute ausgeht ich bin noch am
flughafen angekommen kopf von weg das
problem war nämlich die maschine ist
extrem voll und ich musste mein
handgepäck stoffe abgeben
ein bisschen doof also wenn er jetzt
verloren geht habe ich ein problem weil
dann ist das ganze video von arch
[Musik]
so leute was geht ich bin angekommen ich
bin übrigens auf ewig so habe ich leute
noch gar nicht gesagt koffer ist auch im
staat jetzt gleich wird es ernst die
maske geht mir auf jeden fall so
tierisch auf den sack das tut so weh
jetzt fahren wir auf jeden fall mit dem
taxi zum hafen man jetzt noch einmal
rüber dann bin ich angekommen dann
können wir entspannt den koffer
auspacken und was geht hier ab kleine
schlange leute was geht ab ich bin auf
jeden fall jetzt angekommen auf dem boot
wir müssen jetzt nur noch eben einmal
überfahren und dann sind wir schon da
was ich aber noch ganz vergessen habe
damit bei mir zu hause in der wohnung
auch sauber ist wir können jetzt von
hier aus ganz entspannt den saugroboter
starten und das mache ich mal damit ich
wenn ich wiederkomme auch eine saubere
wohnung haben und wir sehen uns dann
gleich drüben
leute das geht ich bin angekommen wir
sind jetzt in seinem appartement hier
würde ich schon
ich war hier bestimmt schon zehn zwölf
mal obwohl es in bestimmt schon 15 mal
so auf jeden fall weil meine eltern hat
ja mal hin und ich habe jetzt noch
besucht mit dem koffer bleibt nicht böse
wenn ihr manchmal so ein bisschen den
fokus hört ein aktuelles objektiv passt
einfach nicht so genau zu kamera aber
bald habe ich so einen anstieg mikrofon
von sony dann hat sich das erledigt aber
ich weiß wir sind alle hier und jetzt
den inhalt von kupfer abzuchecken
der wiegt übrigens 58 kilo ich habe das
ja eben gesehen als ich den jungs
kofferband gepackt habe also viel kann
da nichts drin sein
also ich habe irgendwie das gefühl da
ist kaum was drin
ich bin eigentlich eine woche hier also
ich hab noch keinen rückflug gebucht
armer sehen
sonst ist klar da und ist auch meinen
rucksack habe ich einen patzer und nun
habe ich schon gesagt okay also wir
können erst mal nichts sagen hieß nichts
und das habe ich nämlich schon mal ja
hier ist leider letzte ich bin mal so
nett und filmen von oben rein ticket da
ich fast nichts drin was das denn ok 18
frisbee oder so wir haben hier einmal
weiße socken das ist schon mal nicht
schlecht wie gesagt ich wusste auch dass
es ein herren koffer ist sozusagen den
urlaubskoffer als sonst hätte das
ganz ja gar keinen sinn gemacht dann
haben wir hier einmal aus zürich haben
wir ja mal eine kurze hose leider ohne
bändchen das ist weg von neid damit kann
man schon mal arbeiten dann haben wir
hier auch nicht schlecht adidas latschen
das hier sind so aufblasbare ja ich
glaube dass sollen einfach sein diese
golden das graffiti drin okay die welt
später mal auf toast und dann haben die
alltags moment bei ihm
guck mal das sind einfach pringles
unterhosen ich musste nicht noch die
gail alter ich wusste nicht mal dass es
sowas gibt und das gute ist auch das ist
nicht ausgepackt also die hat wie man
vorher die tragen dann haben wir hier
noch eine badehose mit äpfeln draufgehen
entschuldigung das sind bieren und auch
ungetragen also hier ist zumindest noch
dieses risiko besteht dass die drum 15
euro ich ziehe mich mal kurz oben mensch
leute was dachte da steht mit badehose
bieren badehose
dann haben wir sogar noch penstox
irgendwas hatte der hand voll geil also
auf jeden fall korrekt dass du mit hinzu
gesteckt hast ein aufblasbarer getränke
kühler eine palm astro ok augen
schlechter
hier haben wir einen gürtel dann hier
ist das imo ein geiles schillings hält
junge geil welche größe ich hoffe mal
etwas für den perfekt passenden arsch
excel leute für uns gesetzen und
restaurant und guck mal was ich anhabe
es ist dieses xxl hawaiihemd ich hatte
noch nie in meinem leben überhaupt so
ein hemd an und jetzt einfach so im
urlaub die ärmel sind auch ziemlich lang
aber ich finde es sieht gar nicht mal so
schlecht oder was meint ihr kann ich
doch durchaus rocken jetzt muss nur noch
jemand um die ecke springen und fragen
wie viel ist ein outfit wert der
natürlich aber weiter geht's mit einem
sporthemd ebenfalls von nike also an
sich gar nicht so schlecht ich dachte
wirklich ich werde damit gar nichts
anfangen können ich werde hier fast gar
keine sachen aber es geht klar dann hier
noch eine rose eine kurze sporthose auch
wieder von nike also erscheint auf jeden
fall ein feld zu sein
dann haben
ja noch ein schwarzes shirt ok einem
print schwarz kann man auch mitarbeiten
einen hut ab ein weingut dann haben wir
auch noch trinken also ich habe prince
andere jetzt komplett die sachen die
hier drin sind sind saic alle frisch
weil also dies jetzt nicht dreckig da
war doch gar nichts mehr geht dann haben
wir hier noch eine sonnenbrille gut so
eine richtige sonnenbrille ist das
glaube ich nicht ich kann auf jeden fall
also irgendwie verdunkelt die kommen
noch ein paar unterhosen und das rennen
okay also wie gesagt paar unterhosen und
das war's dann leider schranken ich muss
sagen mich erinnert das ganze ein
bisschen an ein koffer den ich auch
selber steigerte auch mega viele neue
sachen drin auch alufolie und so ich
frage mich immer wie kommt so etwas
zustande
aber trotzdem sind die sachen gar nicht
mal so schlecht ist natürlich an sich
deutlich zu wenig für eine woche aber
wir checkten das maus und ich nehme hier
auf jeden fall die nächsten tage noch
mit jetzt erst aus dem schrank mit
dieser kuriose und jetzt ist eben meinen
eltern erzählt und normal ist dann immer
so ein bisschen sauer weise weil die
denkt sich so hey bist du dumm du kannst
doch nicht eine woche jeden kann man uns
keine sachen wenn aber ist halt alles
für ein cooles youtube-video leute was
geht
auf geht's zum strand mit meiner fashion
box und der sonnenbrille und mein adidas
geht auf jeden fall klar vom outfit also
so bin ich immer umgerannt leute das
geht wir haben mittlerweile schon am
zweiten tag ich befinde mich gerade auf
dem weg zum strand sowie übrigens das
manchmal so wackelt das ist mit
festbrennweite nehme ich das auf damit
die kamera nicht sofort ist naja was
solls ich habe auf jeden fall diesen
ring dabei das ist das mal gegoogelt er
war ja auch ein koffer achso und mein
outfit einmal hier dieses schwarze t
shirt und einmal hier die frösche nike
rose und dann noch schlappen aber die
gehören nicht mehr
also das ist eigentlich das beste
produkt was im koffer war dieses ding
das liegt nämlich ultra weit der rekord
liegt bei über 400 metern hier vorne
runter ist übrigens dass mehr ich war
schon auf der anderen seite von der
insel da haben wir so richtig schöne
strände
da kann man das richtig abgefahren
vielleicht konnte man gerade schon so
leicht erkennen wozu das dingen fähig
ist wir testen das jetzt gleich am
strand noch mal ich hoffe nur dass es
nicht zu weit rein blick ins meer weil
ich wollte es eigentlich nicht mehr
schwimmen gehen das hier ist übrigens
die apartmentanlage da waren wir früher
immer heute jetzt passt mir ob ich werde
jetzt hier runter ich hoffe der landung
nicht mehr aber gebt euch mal wie weit
das ding fliegt
[Musik]
der wurf war jetzt echt schlecht aber
immerhin das waren bestimmt so 30 35
meter ich muss einfach noch ein bisschen
üben heute mehr habe ich auf jeden fall
bis 55 60 meter geschafft also bis jetzt
habe ich echt mega viel spaß mit dem
kochen wir schauen wir was morgen noch
so geht obwohl ich vielleicht gedacht
habe das video schon morgen zu bringen
aber damit hat erst drei tage hier
gewesen und jetzt muss ich erst mal
irgendwo hier runter kommen um das
reporting und da wieder einzusammeln
perfekt das kann ja was werden was geht
ab leute tag 3 vom koffer experiment
alter das ist alles neu gemacht hier
komme ich denn da es auf dem tennisplatz
das hier ist jetzt das letzte t shirt
aus dem koffer was ich noch nicht an
alte benutzen jetzt zum tennisspielen
und sonst hat sich auf jeden fall alles
an bis jetzt also ich muss morgen safe
schoppmann wir fahren morgen immer in
die stadt spielt also auf jeden fall
noch gegen mein papa tennis und dachte
mir wenn ich mich jetzt hier hinsetze
ist das vielleicht ein cooler abschluss
vom video weil ich kann halt nicht mehr
zeigen außer diese palme die habe ich
noch nicht aufgeblasen ich hoffe ja dass
spaß beim ansehen lass mir super gerne
daumen nach oben da wenn ich das noch
machen soll irgendwann war auf jeden
fall echt easy so also auch für mich hat
es gar kein problem mit und die arbeit
mit den kanal
haut rein das war es von mir ich könne
mir jetzt hier noch drei vier tage
urlaub dann geht es wieder zurück nach
deutschland
achso und zum abschluss hier nochmal die
pringles ochs ja weil und wir haben auch
noch einen pringles unterhose an